so the work energy principle states that
the network done on an object is going
to equal the changing kinetic energy of
that object and this works for systems
as well so the network done on a system
of objects is going to equal the change
in the total kinetic energy of the
object in that system now that sounds
really complicated and technical but i
like to think about the work energy
principle as a shortcut this is a really
nice shortcut that lets me determine the
change in kinetic energy without having
to do a bunch of complicated
conservation of energy equations or
kinematic formulas the catch is that i
need to know how to figure out what the
net work is so how do you figure out
network well the formula for work done
is fd cosine theta since this formula
work energy principle relies on network
this has to be magnitude of the net
force
times magnitude of the distance traveled
times cosine of theta remember this
theta has to be angle between
not any angle angle between the net
force direction and the direction of
motion and so let's let's try this out
how do you use this thing let's kick the
tires let's say there's a satellite it's
moving to the right and there's a net
force on this satellite now this net
force could go in any direction
if the net force has a component in the
direction of motion then the network's
going to be positive and if so anything
here from like negative 90
well i guess like negative 89.9 because
90 would be perpendicular from any for
like 89.9 negative to positive 89.9
you've got a component in the direction
of motion that means you're going to be
doing positive network and that means
the change in kinetic energy will be
positive because it just equals that
number that means kinetic energy
increases you're going to be speeding up
and that kind of it makes sense
intuitively if your force is in the
direction of motion you're speeding up
uh what about the other case what if
your net force points in the opposite
direction of motion well now the
network's going to be negative you'll
have a negative change in kinetic energy
in other words you're going to slow down
and if the net force points
perpendicular well then you're not doing
any work because cosine of 90 is going
to be zero
no net work would be done there's going
to be no change in kinetic energy that
doesn't mean you stop it just means
you're not going to speed up or slow
down
this does something you might be like
doesn't it do something yeah you're
going to drift upward you're going to
start changing your direction but this
is not going to be doing any work on you
at that moment
and so just to be clear let me let's
just try a complicated one here let's
say this force
goes in some direction let's say your
velocity even goes down so i mean maybe
your satellite is heading downward and
your force is going to go in any
direction well if it goes this way
exactly backwards it can be 180 you're
gonna be doing negative work you're
gonna be slowing down decreasing kinetic
energy and you're not gonna change
direction if you're like this you have a
component opposite so you're gonna be
slowing down and a changing direction
this will just be changing direction
you're not speeding up or slowing down
at that moment
this will speed you up and change your
direction and finally this will just be
speeding you up and you will not be
changing your direction so the work
energy principle is convenient to just
get a conceptual or qualitative idea of
what's going on and it can obviously
also give you an idea of how to
calculate things so let's try let's try
one we actually have to get a number so
let's say there's a hot air balloon and
it's a 300 kilogram hot air balloon
drifting to the left i had an initial
speed of seven meters per second and
it's traveling a total of 50 meters to
the left during this journey now there's
gonna be forces on this hot air balloon
obviously there's gonna be gravity and
some buoyant force but
because these are perpendicular to the
direction of motion they do no work and
so when we're going to use this work
energy principle they're not even going
to factor in we don't even have to know
these since they were perpendicular and
did no work you only consider the forces
in the direction of motion so say there
was a wind gust helping you to the left
here of 200 newtons but this is a big
bulky balloon not that aerodynamic and
so there was a drag force from air
resistance of 104 newtons to the right
what we want to know is
we want to determine the final speed of
the hot air balloon after it travels 50
meters directly to the left with the
forces shown now there's lots of
different ways to do this you know
newton's laws you can do
kinematic formulas all kinds of stuff
even momentum technically impulse but
the easiest i'm pretty sure the easiest
way to do this is just going to be the
work energy principle which states that
the net work done is going to equal the
change in kinetic energy so let's go
ahead and do it so we know that net work
is equal to the magnitude of the net
force times the magnitude of the
distance traveled times cosine of the
angle between them what's changing
kinetic energy mean well change in
anything is final minus initial so since
kinetic energy is one half mv squared
this is just going to be one half m v
final squared minus one half
m
the initial squared so this is going to
be the change in kinetic energy final
minus initial all right let's plug in
numbers here so net force how do we get
that vertical pieces don't matter we're
just looking horizontally here those are
the only ones that gonna affect it these
vertical ones just cancel so we have 200
to the left 104 to the right so we have
to subtract those to get 96 to the left
and we just want magnitude so i'm going
to get
96 newtons to the left not negative or
anything i'm just taking magnitude times
the distance traveled we know that's 50
so we get times 50
meters
cosine of the angle now this is careful
you might be like oh 180 here but no the
net force points to the left this 200 is
winning here so leftward net force and
the leftward direction the angle between
these two is zero
cosine of zero is just one we're maxed
out here so
net force points in the direction of
motion so equals let's plug in the rest
of this one half the mass is 300
kilograms times v final squared that's
what we want to determine minus
one-half
300 kilograms
times the initial speed is seven meters
per second so we got seven
meters per second squared well 96 times
50 is going to come out to
4800 that means
that's the net work done notice that's
joules that's how much energy we've
added that's the change in kinetic
energy so we know the network is
changing kinetic energy we've added 4
800 joules of kinetic energy that's
going to have to equal
half of 300 is 150
kilograms times v final squared
minus if you take a half of 300 times 7
squared you're going to get 73.50
so this is how much energy the hot air
balloon started with initially so i have
to move that to the left we add those
together i'm going to get 12
150 joules is how much kinetic energy
the balloon ends with and that's got to
equal 150
kilograms times v final squared i could
divide 12 150 by 150 and you get exactly
81
and that's going to equal v final
squared and if you take a square root of
that you get exactly nine so the final
velocity of this hot air balloon is nine
meters per second it's sped up
that's not surprising this net force was
directed leftward and the object was
moving leftward so we're doing positive
work we're increasing the kinetic energy
we started with seven meters per second
we ended with nine meters per second and
this is an example of how you use the
work energy principle so to recap the
work energy principle states the network
is equal to the change in kinetic energy
this can help you just conceptually or
qualitatively determine whether
something's going to speed up slow down
or change direction or both and then
quantitatively you can use this to
specifically solve for the change in
kinetic energy as well as the final or
initial speed something might have had